this is really promising news live
entertainment is soon going to be
returning to mgm resorts on the las
vegas strip
the company plans to reopen seven shows
starting november 6th with new safety
protocols of course in place
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
is live on las vegas boulevard with the
new guidelines
and also what to expect when it comes to
attending one of those shows
kristen denise it's been nearly eight
months since
live entertainment went dark on the
strip but mgm resorts international
announced today it's slowly bringing
back its shows to its properties
here's a list of the seven shows
returning to excalibur
luxor and mgm grand next month they
include mainstays like
david copperfield and top just to name a
couple
mgm says shows will have limited
capacity
and in some cases that's requiring the
performance to now be in larger theaters
to increase distancing in the audience
the state also mandates at least 25 feet
between the stage
and closest audience member now despite
a few changes coming
many involved with the productions
welcome the return of live entertainment
on november 6.
the staff the crew everyone's just
excited to get back to work just to be
on stage that's our passion
you know it's not a hobby it's our life
the show must go on you know
vegas is not backed with the way it was
before so i think the capacity kind of
suits whatever vegas is right now
[Music]
the mgm resorts website shows the
entertainment operational enhancements
that includes regular cleaning of venues
between shows
requiring guests to wear masks and
answer health screening questions
mgm encourages digital ticket sales and
contactless scanning of them
caesar's entertainment is also welcoming
back live entertainment
this month the show's ex-country will
welcome guests back this thursday
absinthe as well as piff the magic
dragon
plan to reopen next week reporting live
near the strip kristen robin
it is now